Speaker 1: Good news out of Michigan, where
under the leadership of Democratic Governor
Gretchen Whitmer, Michigan has repealed an
insane 1931 abortion ban.
This is really wacky stuff.
The Detroit Free Press reports.
Whitmer repeals Michigan's 1931 abortion ban
with the stroke of a pen.
Governor Gretchen Whitmer repealed an unenforceable
Michigan law Wednesday that makes it a felony
to administer most abortions, with no exception
for rape or incest.
Now, unenforceable, unenforceable is a critical
word here.
And so the reason to do this is less about
the idea that that law would start to be enforced
right now, but the idea that it could be enforced
depending on what continues to happen at the
highest court of the land, the Supreme Court
in the United States.
And this is a very, very good thing.
It is important to understand that this is
only the beginning of what is certain to be
a much longer, I guess we would call it crusade
against abortion that started decades ago
with the passage of Roe v Wade.
Roe v Wade was about ensuring right to an
abortion, but it triggered the battle against
abortion from the American right.
They had a major success recently when the
Supreme Court did away with Roe v Wade.
And we know that it is only the beginning.
Here is Governor Gretchen Whitmer officially
signing a repeal of that abortion ban.
Speaker 2: That's what I about.
Speaker 1: All right.
So most of us understand what it looks like
to sign a piece of paper.
And here is Gretchen Whitmer actually saying
something about this just ahead of the signing.
Speaker 2: I don't ever want someone from
the press to ask me again, should we talk
about abortion or the economy?
If you don't think abortion is about the economy,
you might not have a uterus.
Right?
We know that the decision when and whether
or not to bear a child is the most consequential
decision economically that a family or a woman
will make in her lifetime.
The government has no business getting in
the way of conversations between women and
their doctors.
Speaker 1: This should not really be controversial,
but it did send the American right into a
tizzy, hurling the term Marxist at Gretchen
Whitmer.
I don't know why.
Getting rid of an insane law from 1931 makes
you a marxist in 2023.
I don't think they know either.
I don't think they know what Marxist even
means.
But that doesn't matter, because what we do
see is their passion.
If you want to use that word for making it
as difficult as possible to get an abortion
under any circumstances and anywhere in the
United States.
And so this is a small step.
Again, at this point, this was an unenforceable
1931 law.
But it is still important to get these laws
off the books.
And many states, particularly red states,
have these retrograde ancient laws on the
books, even if they aren't being enforced
right now.
Any one of these that can be taken off the
table in terms of possible future enforcement
should be considered a win.
And remember, Governor Gretchen Whitmer, easily,
easily winning reelection in November, despite
a challenge from Trump endorsed MAGA candidate
Tudor Dickson, who went down in flames.
And we can all be very, very happy about that.
We'll continue following this fight for just
simple medical rights.
That's what we're talking about here.
We'll take a break.
Make sure you subscribe to the YouTube channel
at YouTube.com slash The David Pakman Show.
What a program we have for you today.
This one is good enough that we might actually
record it.
The David Pakman Show is an audience funded
program.
If you appreciate the work that we do, I welcome
you to sign up at join Packman dot com.
You can use the coupon code indicted or you
can use the coupon code indicated in case
you accidentally or deliberately misspell
indicted the way Donald Trump did indicated
the coupon code will still work.
You'll get access to the daily bonus show,
commercial free audio and video streams of
the show, invitations to member only town
halls, as well as access to the soundboard.
It mirrors my soundboard that I have here.
Speaker 3: David Pakman does not have a soul.
He doesn't have a soul, right?
Speaker 1: That soundboard you have access
to as a member as well.
You can sign up at join packman dot com coupon
codes indicted or indicated